[Musique]
activité nos associations dans les
cadets de la gendarmerie ou dans les
chez jeunes sapeurs-pompiers et puis
après on les invite à s'engager plus
longuement et là ça peut prendre la
forme d'un engagement entre trois mois
et un an service civique ou réserve
militaire ou engagement aussi pour faire
rayonner la France à l'étranger dans le
cadre de la coopération ou du
volontariat international là je
regardais j'ai un programme tiens au
lycée Beaulieu à Auch bon donc 12 jours
les thèmes les thèmes tournent vraiment
les activités tournent c'est pas des
colonies de vacances absolument pas ça
tourne autour de la citoyenneté il y a
une grande caricature qui est faite en
ce moment du service national universel
et c'est aussi pour ça que je voulais
être à votre antenne pour pouvoir
échanger beaucoup le comparent soit à la
colonie de vacances soit à notre service
militaire qu'on a connu en réalité c'est
ni une colonie de vacances ni le service
militaire et parce que on a l'habitude
de de comparer par rapport à ce qu'on
des choses qu'on connaît je me dis bah
c'est le moment peut-être de casser ses
caricatures et dire ce que c'est c'est
de la citoyenneté c'est les gestes qui
sauvent c'est des moments de débat
d'éducation aux médias c'est des moments
où on se dépasse mais c'est aussi des
moments on se dit quel citoyen je peux
devenir et quelle place je peux prendre
dans notre pays on a le plus beau pays
au monde mais pour aimer la France et
bien il faut la prendre à l'aimer et
donc il faut la rencontrer on a des
valeurs extrêmement fortes mais l'idée
c'est de leur faire vivre ces valeurs à
ces jeunes et leur dire dépassez-vous
nous avons besoin de vous mais vous nous
avons besoin de VOUS ensemble et c'est
le projet du service national universel
les jeunes portent un uniforme
alors je lis les thèmes lundi 20 février
donc dans ce séjour de cohésion dans le
Gers matinée intégration après-midi
atelier autour des valeurs de la
République et jeu de cohésion la laïcité
l'égalité la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on met beaucoup de
choses sur les épaules de l'école on a
vu à quel point c'est tout n'est pas
facile au sein de l'école et donc on
veut vivre une mixité territoriale et
sociale en dehors de sa classe parce que
ça permet de libérer la parole et de
voir d'autres jeunes Français différents
de soi mais avec lesquels on peut faire
communauté nationale pour l'instant ces
confidentiel 2000 essénes en 2019-2020
broyer le covid 2021 15000 et 2022 32000
plus de 50 000 jeunes plus de 50 000
jeunes Français dans notre pays ce sont
engagés dans ce service national
universel et c'est grâce à eux qu'on a
fait améliorer et bien le séjour la
mission d'intérêt général mais aussi les
engagements longs avec je parlais du
service civique et dans le fond 50000
jeunes qui se qui sont dans un parcours
pour être plus civique plus citoyen plus
engagé et qui dans le fond a rencontré
la France en vivant cette expérience
assez unique alors je le disais pour
l'instant ce sont des volontaires et ce
qu'il faut rendre le SNU obligatoire on
en parle juste après la pause n'est pas
obligatoire il est facultatif on
s'inscrit et on y participe est-ce qu'il
doit devenir obligatoire qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous appelez le 39 21
cette question je vous la pose est-ce
que vous souhaitez que votre votre parce
que c'est vous qui en avez la charge
aujourd'hui le service national
universel en tout cas devient
obligatoire est-ce que vous le souhaitez
vous savez moi j'ai travaillé d'abord
pourquoi on l'a fait et je vous dirais
quels sont les hypothèses qu'on a posé
la table sur la table d'abord on avait
on a la certitude après le covid qu'on a
besoin que les jeunes se rencontrent et
c'est une réalité on nous aurons besoin
de faire ensemble ils ont besoin de
mieux comprendre la France regardez
aujourd'hui comme à quel point les
jeunes ne votent pas ou ne votent plus
aux élections on a besoin qu'ils
découvrent les formes d'engagement les
métiers qui permettent de rendre fiers
de bâtir notre pays on a besoin de plus
de vivre ensemble mais pas dans les mots
dans les actes c'est-à-dire des moments
où les jeunes sortent de leurs
établissements scolaires des
associations dans lesquelles ils ont
qu'ils ont l'habitude de découvrir on a
besoin d'égalité des chances on a besoin
que ils prennent confiance encore plus
fortement en eux en apprenant des choses
qui leur permettent de se dépasser je
pense au gestes qui sauvent je pense
finalement à la possibilité de réagir
s'il y a un incendie ou une nation et
tout ça et bien c'est complémentaire à
ce qu'on fait à l'école et ses
complémentaires en réalité à ses
apprentissages et donc vivre en
communauté et vivre en communauté
nationale ça ne se décrète pas ça se
bâtit et pour ça le service national
universel pour le généraliser parce que
c'est la demande qui m'a été faite par
le Président de la République je
m'appuie sur deux grandes institutions
nos armées puisque je suis rattaché au
ministre Sébastien Lecornu et à
l'éducation nationale au ministre
papenzaï et grâce à l'expertise et
l'expérience de ces des grandes maisons
ma mission c'est de le généraliser ça
veut dire quoi concrètement
concrètement le généraliser ça veut dire
soit le rendre dans le parcours le temps
scolaire est dans le parcours scolaire
pour tous les jeunes ça c'est une des
hypothèses c'est la première en disant
comment on permet à chaque jeune de
France quel que soit sa situation
sociale quel que soit son territoire
quel que soit sa religion d'avoir la
chance et bien de se retrouver en dehors
de sa classe en dehors de sa ville de
son département et de prendre conscience
à quel point c'est une chance de
rencontrer des jeunes différents et la
place dont on a
pour qu'il peut prendre dans notre pays
ou de le faire sur le temps des vacances
scolaires et donc du coup sur le temps
volontaire et de leur permettre
finalement et bien de d'aller chercher
quelque chose qu'il ne trouve nulle part
ailleurs parce que c'est ni le service
militaire de l'époque ni la colonie de
vacances alors on est avec Josette donc
sur le caractère obligatoire il y a deux
hypothèses voilà il y a deux hypothèses
sur la table et j'ai travaillé sur les
deux bon et et
c'est pas impossible qu'il y ait des
annonces dans les prochains mois
prochaines de la République a eu
l'occasion de le dire d'ailleurs dans
ces vœux en fin d'année on a besoin de
renforcer la force morale de notre pays
et ça passe par la force et la confiance
de notre jeunesse et donc il aura
l'occasion de d'exprimer tout le
parcours d'engagement dans dans un
certain temps très bien très bien Joseph
nous appelle du Rhône bonjour Josette
vous êtes retraités vous êtes tout à
fait pour le SNU c'est un mélange de la
société c'est un brassage social tout à
fait
je trouve à ce service qui doit être
obligatoire c'est que les jeunes de tous
les milieux vont se rencontrer et voir
donc d'autres jeunes et puis ils vont
aussi apprendre si ça dure suffisamment
longtemps et si vivre ensemble ils vont
apprendre une certaine discipline et ça
c'est très important parce que beaucoup
de jeunes maintenant vivent j'allais
dire à leur façon ne s'impose aucune
une règle on la vit en société c'est
précisément d'obéir à certaines règles
et ils apprendront aussi la civilité
voilà vous vous dites que vos deux
filles sont faits de service militaire à
l'époque et ont appris beaucoup de
choses
ah oui
dans
[Musique]
maman il pense qu'à boire et à tomber
les filles vraiment sur le tombe de haut
bon oui et l'autre fils qui était dans
l'écriture alpin lui il avait c'était
déjà à la maison mais il a vraiment vu
la solidarité c'était vraiment au
contraire c'était pas du tout il nous
expliquait qu'il y en avait un qui était
vraiment tête en l'air et bien quand il
partait en montagne il me disait on est
tous là un peu alternée à lui dire
pierre t'as pas oublié des chaussettes
de rechange t'as pas et je me suis
trouvé que ça c'était magnifique aussi
voilà c'est le groupe c'est l'équipe
c'est la solidarité Sarah et ben merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame de votre
témoignage vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est vous êtes dans les 75% des
Français qui souhaitent un service
national universel plutôt obligatoire
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que oui
il faut qu'ils apprennent de la
solidarité entre eux et un pays fort
c'est un pays dont sa jeunesse et bien
et forte et la de la solidarité entre
elle mais aussi un cadre commun et ce
cadre commun c'est un peu le projet le
matin il se lève ils ont un rythme
effectivement bien soutenu il faut
ensemble quel que soit leur situation
sociale et bien il mange la même chose
il faut l'effort en collectif et surtout
il faut comprendre que je crois que ça
développe de la responsabilité parce
qu'on n'est pas entouré de son papa de
sa maman de ses habitudes on n'a pas son
téléphone portable durant la journée et
donc du coup dans le fond et bien ça
nous pousse et bien aller chercher ce
qu'on a au plus profond de soi et donc
ça fait grandir et ça aujourd'hui et
bien je crois que notre jeunesse elle en
a besoin surtout dans un moment où il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de défis pareil
comment faire de la discipline 800 000
jeunes seraient appelés aussi c'est lui
devient obligatoire en tout cas si toute
une classe d'âge s'inscrivait bon vous
auriez 800000 jeunes par an sur les bras
j'allais dire bon va falloir faire de la
discipline comment est-ce que vous
encadrez ces jeunes vous savez moi ce
qui se passe dans certaines écoles quand
même c'est là où c'est là où c'est
différent de l'école et c'est
complémentaires en même temps
aujourd'hui le service national
universel il est encadré par trois types
de familles d'encadrant le premier c'est
des hommes et des femmes qui viennent de
l'éducation nationale alors ça peut être
des CPE des proviseurs des enseignants
souvent des enseignants d'histoires géo
ou de sport de SVT c'est aussi un tiers
qui viennent du monde associatif sportif
éducation populaire c'est les hommes et
des femmes qui accompagnent nos scout
nos colos mais aussi beaucoup les
équipes sportives et enfin un tiers de
médecins qui ont porté l'uniforme et qui
ont servi la France des anciens pompiers
des anciens militaires ou des anciens
policiers et donc la culture des trois
nous permet de poser un cadre vous avez
vu l'emploi du temps dans le Gers ça
Hoche il est soutenu il se lève le matin
il lève notre drapeau ensuite le soir
par exemple ils ont des temps de
discussion de débat c'est une sorte ça
ressemble un peu à des veillées dans le
fond mais ces débats ça leur permet de
se comprendre d'aller plus loin et pas
être dans des postures et notre pays il
a besoin de sortir des postures mais
aujourd'hui sur les quelques de milliers
de jeunes qui qui s'inscrivent ce sont
essentiellement des jeunes qui viennent
de familles où on les pousse plutôt à
s'inscrire qui ont peut-être d'ailleurs
une conscience politique bon sur les 750
000 autres il y aura pas toujours un
engouement certain comment est-ce que
vous comptez les gérer il y aura
peut-être des des individus un petit peu
plus compliqués moi je suis moi je suis
convaincu que c'est pas c'est surtout du
vivre ensemble c'est apprendre le
collectif aujourd'hui il y a 9 jeunes
sur 10 quand ils le font ils sont
extrêmement satisfaits et parfois ils
viennent parce que leurs parents ont
décidé qu'ils allaient le faire ils
avaient pas très envie de le faire et
puis au bout de un jour de jour il se
rendent compte à quel point et bien ils
sont libérés du cadre de d'habitude ils
découvrent autre chose moi je suis
convaincu parce que cette satisfaction
elle est dans les mots et le témoignage
des parents voire des jeunes qui l'ont
fait je trouve que c'est le plus fort je
suis convaincu que apprendre à vivre
ensemble ça prendra se respecter et à
prendre de la différence de l'autre et
ça se fait quand l'encadrement le permet
c'est pour ça que l'internat est
important quitter son département c'est
important André nous appelle de
Strasbourg juriste bonjour André merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur Europe 1
dans Europe 1 midi qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous du bonjour bonjour
que pensez-vous du caractère obligatoire
du SMU
je trouve ce FMU un gadget un gadget
pour l'instant parce que ça fait
volontaire donc c'est une espèce de club
un peu comme il y a les léoses chez les
Lions un peu comme bien les scouts un
club volontaire entre gens qui se
ressemblent donc ça ne crée pas
véritablement une intégration mais le
jour le jour où cette sauce obligatoire
alors ça j'y crois encore moins ce sera
pour reprendre l'expression du président
de la République qui avait fait imbroger
le service militaire
abracadabrantes il avait employé le
terme
qu'on peut retenir
sont déjà fait bien avant vous pensez
vraiment mélanger des jeux des jeunes du
16e ou du 7e arrondissement ou de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye avec ceux des
Minguettes ou ceux de gagner ou de
Bobigny ils sont à 15 ans ou à 16 ans
déjà tellement différents par les par
les chances et les malchances qu'ils ont
eu dans leur vie que par définition
ça ça ne marchera pas
obligatoire il y aura comme du temps du
vrai service minéraux de l'ancien
service militaire puis certes était
différent il y aura des femmes droits il
y aura des combines il y aura du piston
et des magouilles pour pas oublier qu'à
la fin du service militaire
effectivement il y en avait certains qui
qui le faisait et les autres qui avaient
plus de chance plus de connexion pouvait
faire des ce qu'on appelait des SMS en
entreprise en avant on allait on allait
faire son service à Hong Kong on allait
faire son service au bout du monde Sarah
et La Haye moi je refuse de de
d'entendre que c'est un gadget pour les
jeunes qui l'ont fait moi j'ai vu ces
jeunes ils ont donné 15 jours de leur
temps de leurs vacances pour aller à
prendre à être ensemble les gestes qui
sauvent il y a eu des témoignages de
jeunes filles ou jeunes garçons qui par
exemple subissent des violences on a du
saisir le procureur de la République il
y a des jeunes filles et je m'en
souviens d'une en particulier qui avait
fait pour la première fois un bilan de
santé on s'est rendu compte qu'elle ne
voyait pas bien et donc à cause de ça
elle est en échec scolaire dans le
service national de universel
aujourd'hui déjà de Trappes partent en
ce jour avec des jeunes du 16e ou du 17e
arrondissement de Paris et il se
retrouve avec des jeunes occitans il se
trouve que je vous raconte exactement ce
qui s'est passé il y a à peine quelques
jours puisque c'était les séjours qui
viennent de se clôturer des jeunes
d'Île-de-France étaient en Occitanie et
les jeunes d'Occitanie étaient en
Île-de-France a cachant ou ailleurs et
dans le fond cette mixité sociale là et
cette mixité territoriale c'est la
garantie et bien de la construction de
ce vivre ensemble ils apprennent des
choses qui les font grandir ce n'est pas
c'est loin d'être un gadget et pour le
coup pour vous convaincre je vous invite
à regarder les témoignages de ces jeunes
ce qu'ils en disent eux et à quel point
ils sont fiers de participer à la
construction d'une société FRANCE plus
témoigner mais mes confrères du Midi
Libre et créer un reportage encore une
fois à ce jour ce sont des jeunes qui
ont choisi d'y aller ça sera peut-être
une autre limonade comme on dit et quand
ça sera obligatoire mais bon c'est pour
eux c'est pour ça qu'on le construit
Fabrice nous appelle de Paris je suis
père de famille d'ado et j'ai connu le
service militaire bonjour Fabrice
oui bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur Europe 1 qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez la ministre vous écoute alors
très bien
sa positif de rendre obligatoire moi je
me rappelle voilà évidemment je fais un
parallèle avec le service militaire j'ai
bien compris que la ministre a bien dit
que c'était quelque chose différent donc
ça je l'ai bien compris mais j'en fais
un parallèle parce que bon je l'ai fait
en 93 à l'origine quand j'y suis allé
j'y suis allé avec un a priori et
évidemment j'avais pas forcément envie
d'y aller et finalement j'en ai tiré une
expérience qui a été extrêmement
intéressante et qui m'a permis tout au
long de ma vie finalement
de m'en servir et ça a été une
expérience vraiment extrêmement
régissante pourquoi parce que c'est le
seul moment de sa vie où on se retrouve
dans un cadre complètement différent
dans une bulle sociale par exemple qui
est différent on se retrouve avec tout
le monde avec pas mal de monde avec des
horizons et d'ailleurs j'entendais
l'auditeur juste avant qui disait on va
les classer ceux du 16e par rapport à
ceux du 93 justement c'était justement
ça l'intérêt c'était se mélange là et je
trouve ça extrêmement positif je reviens
juste sur les adolescents aujourd'hui je
pense que ils ont connu ces dernières
années en plus des expériences
difficiles avec le covid le confinement
donc tout ça permet de pouvoir avoir une
expérience
les adolescents d'aujourd'hui comme nous
on l'était
on se laisse aller un peu quelquefois
laisse les parents s'occuper de
certaines tâches etc etc et je pense que
toutes ces expériences là même pour eux
peuvent leur permettre d'avoir une
expérience qui derrière
professionnellement aura un intérêt donc
effectivement ça paraît pour les
adolescents quelque chose une contrainte
ils auront peut-être pas forcément envie
d'y aller mais je vous garantis qu'en
tant qu'expérience c'est une expérience
extrêmement réticante et qu'on ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs dans sa vie
en tout cas au départ et on plus tard au
niveau professionnel mais je pense que
c'est un bon tremplin et une très bonne
expérience merci beaucoup Fabrice merci
de nous avoir rappelé au 39-21 Sarah et
Lary voilà on les retrouve les 75% de
français favorable ouais c'est nul
obligatoire c'est une dernière question
vous avez parfois des difficultés à
trouver des animateurs vous avez créé
une aide de 200 € pour les baffes pour
ceux qui passent le BAFA c'est le
diplôme pour avoir ensuite de devenir
animateur et s'occuper de de jeunes ça a
fonctionné ça a très très bien
fonctionné on a dépassé tous les records
cette année c'est plus de 50 000 jeunes
qui ont passé le BAFA plus de 37%. et
vous savez pourquoi c'est parce que le
service national universel dans sa
globalité c'est un parcours et
l'animation on a besoin de plus de
jeunes qui s'engagent pour encadrer
d'autres jeunes donc le BAFA mais aussi
pour participer à du lien
intergénérationnel dans nos EHPAD avec
l'animation pour nos personnes plus
âgées et dans le fond c'est de leur
donner les clés et c'est ce qu'on
souhaite à tout âge à ses anciens
moments où il y a des chamboulés de
beaucoup d'émotions mais je suis
convaincue quand on leur donne les clés
et bien ils savent sans saisir et bât IR
leur vie je crois que c'est ça la chance
et le rêve français merci beaucoup Sarah
et